I'm Paul Clifton I'm 30 years old I am a
sixth grade teacher leader and my salary
is about $60,000 I'm a new teacher
leader and so I get to coach other
teachers fellow math teachers and more
common team only to observe teachers
teach to co-teach with them and get into
other classrooms instead of just working
in my own times the mcglone we we
collaborate so much and it's a great
opportunity to be a part of that I'm an
ela s teacher so that means that in the
classroom I use Spanish and English to
teach a lot of times I'll translate
which which is I'll go back and forth
between English and Spanish just to help
everyone understand we have a lot of
language learners at our school so
there's so many students that have the
potential to be bilingual and biliterate
it's so so important that we're using
both languages and helping them
understand that that Spanish has just as
much value and validity as English even
though I went through the teaching
college and everything like that to call
the courses like that first day I was
still I was still super nervous and and
you know I can't say I was fully
prepared and no still still progressing
every day but I don't think there's
possible to be fully prepared to become
a teacher I remember that first day I
had this like huge just like nervous
feeling and scared and fear you know and
and uh there's always like the best
times for you to grow and so being able
to get through kind of like I have in
that first day but the first week after
that it was like oh man okay this is
what I'm supposed to be doing employers
and principals are looking for people
who are really reflective and really on
their practice and have that girl 4
mindset to continue to grow and and
progress we have such a big emphasis in
our school around coaching and you know
that that progress you make as a teacher
definitely in the interview that's one
of the main questions that that is asked
like do or do we feel comfortable being
videotaped do we feel comfortable with
like in the moment coaching and a lot of
times you're going to be
to teach a lesson and then few minutes
after you teach it reflect on that
lesson and and pick out things that you
did well and what way you could improve
on so definitely
principals are looking for people that
reflect on their practice and are
willing to grow I feel like being a
black male teacher in the elementary
going into becoming an elementary
teacher is it's really gave me an
advantage in finding a job being
bilingual so there was a lot that I
brought to the table naturally that
helped me find a job but I do like I do
recognize that it can be tough for
teachers especially if you're not a math
or a science teacher to find a job and
and maintain it I know that it's so
important for kids especially nowadays
where they have access to you know so
much technology that they that they have
experiences with black males who are
positive and in that are in schools that
are serving kids and that are teaching
with love I feel like without that it's
tough for it give me a lot they're gonna
be really tough for kids to see
themselves being more than what is shown
to them on TV or or through music they
might not drive that you have to have to
become a teacher like you would be
successful in anything right but you
know definitely having that passion for
teaching it's not easy it's really it's
really difficult like you have to teach
on the fly you have to think and change
your instruction and as you go you have
to be humble every day because you like
what you're teaching isn't working so
you have to change it up in some way